[Music]
my typical flowers
I'll start them with four petal
anti-spin or two petal in spin and most
people I know who do a lot of tech boy
boy flowers that's also how they get
people started then interesting thing
about those moves as you might know is
it takes three Poyser khals to make a
for petal aunty spin or a to peddle in
spin so check out the pattern for pill
aunty spin the poi points down three
times the bottom the side the other side
so only takes three downs of the poi
makes a four petal flower same thing is
true for a two in spin the play points
down at points down at points down down
down down
it never points down at the top now the
office is true if you do your you're in
spin to the top and bottom then it only
points down at the top the very bottom
is pointing up and if you do box aunty
spin it points down at the top and it
points up at the bottom but that's all a
good place to start and if that's
totally confusing go through all those
videos I have up talking about for
peddled anti spin and to in spins
because it's a good place to start it
makes a lot of sense because it's all
symmetrical because if you're making a
four petal auntie spin it's the same top
to bottom as it is front to back it's
very easy to understand you can slice it
anyway and it's mirror symmetry you
could do one circle at each quadrant and
that's how a lot of people want to start
it's not necessarily bad it just
confuses people sometimes so for
instance I could go down down down down
down down down down I can do it down at
every position that's okay it makes a
five-pointed flower like kind of an
upside down starfish
but if you don't like your starfish
being nauseous you could also do an up
at every point and make an upward
pointing 5 petaled flower up up up up up
up up up up up up up up up up now that's
got lots of awesome sauce in many ways
and if you say were to do some arms
office and pull up assets it's pretty
easy to put together I could go see
right forward left backward and my arms
opposite and they go down down down and
everything's pretty easy peasy and I've
got two upside-down starfish which I
always think looks a little unfortunate
for the starfish so I like putting my
starfish up up up up up I like upward
pointing starfish upward pointing five
because it looks more like the classic
star we grew up with a pentagram it's a
power I'm controlling I wish I could I
get you to send me money or
cryptocurrency but I can't so we have
our upward pointing five petal flowers
the trouble is it can be a little more
difficult to see and feel whether you've
got all the points equally spaced magic
takes practice where it gets really
confusing is if you wanted to do
something like say poi forward split
time arms backwards split time because
then things get really weird because if
um when my right arm if it's pointing up
at the top while my left arm is down my
left arm if I'm split time has to point
down at the bottom because the right
point always points up with the left by
points down the left point always points
down the right place up that's what
split time is so there's a moment where
I go right up left down when the right
arms up the poi is up when the left arm
is down left boy is down but look my
left boy if it's up at the top it's also
up at the bottom if I'm doing four
circles the left poi if it's
down at the bottom it's awesomely down
at the top because it's also doing four
circles put them together get strange
because it's gonna go like this when my
rights up and my left is down the point
away from me
well my left is up in the right is down
they point in like a box anti-spin so a
point away they point together they
point which is really weird feeling it's
very possible so makes ten pointed
flower which is awesome and I fully
recommend learning it it just confuses
people if they're new at flowers and
being flowers can be in the beginning
pretty difficult I remember I had to put
like on one wall a sign saying arm
forward play up and the other wall arm
backward poi down just to remember which
way the poi in the arms were going but
there you have it you that's why or one
of the reasons many people start people
with three circle patterns which make
for an T spinner to in spin there's lots
of cool patterns you can do with four
circles and I recommend going there
because there's all kinds of cool stuff
in there and that is some thoughts on
four circle in spin and anti-spin
plateless
this is the Bay of Fundy 40-foot tides
let's see if it'll switch focus then
switch Falcons 10 like 12 meter tides
right here the water goes up and down
about 40 feet about 40 feet every day
it's a pretty incredible
[Music]
and not too far down there is keep split
it's a big split of land that goes over
halfway across the Bay of Fundy
and every day a peak inflow or outflow
there is as much water passing the tip
of Cape split as all the rivers in the
world combined okay I have to admit I I
read that on the Internet
so don't take that as you will I have
been the tip of Cape split and I've
watched how much water passes and it's
an incredible amount of water and I've
been to a lot of big rivers like the st.
Lawrence River and the Amazon and some
big rivers and I I do believe it could
be true that it's as much water as all
the rivers in the world combined
[Music]
but just you know when somebody like boy
spin around the internet tells you
something they could take with a grain
of salt
[Music]
and if you do want to set me
cryptocurrencies you can send it to this
address right here and I'll link to it
below
[Music]